هذه هي سمه المدن الاراديه تظاهرات
متواصلات تحيط بالنظام وتضرب اقتصاد
البلاد المنهر في مقتل في خضم عقوبات تلو
اخرى
ليتراجع الريال الايراني المتعثر الى
مستوى منخفض جديد مقابل الدولار مع
استمرار الاحتجاجات والاضرابات العماليه
والاسواق وتزايد عزله البلاد وسط
الانتقادات الغربيه للاجراءات الامنيه
الصارمه التي يتخذها النظام تجاه المحتجين
حيث كان يتم بيع الدولار بما يصل الى
300,000 ريال في ما ارتفع بعد الاحتجاجات
الى اكثر من
370,000 ريال
وفقد الريال قرابه 14% من قيمته منذ
اندلاع الاحتجاجات على مستوى البلاد عقب
مقتل سامي
قفزه كبيره انعكست هي الاخرى على ارتفاع
الاسعار مع عدم قدره النظام على دفع رواتب
المتقاعدين ما دفع بهم للتجمع في وقفات
احتجاجيه اضافه الى اضرابات في قطاعات
النفط والغاز هو البذر كيماويات في
المحافظات الجنوبيه احتجاجا على الغلاء
والظروف المعيشيه الصعبه والتاخر في دفع
الرواتب
التحام التظاهرات بالاضرابات ذلك ما يخشاه
النظام الايراني الامر الذي قد يؤدي الى
شل البلاد وحركتها الاقتصاديه المناكه
عصام عبد السلام العربيه